- I changed my party affiliation
because I just don't
feel like it's,
I just couldn't live
with my conscience
to be a Democrat anymore
after working on the new book.
I just felt like it's just,
I have questions about even,
I mean, I'm sticking
with California,
I'm going to fight to
save California like you,
but I feel like I'm living
in Apartheid South
Africa or something,
I just feel like I'm living
in a place that's not moral.
And I feel really bad
and angry about that.
We don't want to move, but
the state is pretty terrible.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the president of
Environmental Progress
and author of the new book,
"San Franc-sicko: Why
Progressives Ruin Cities,"
Michael Shellenberger, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks for having me, Dave.
Good to see you again.
- So last time that I saw you
was about three years ago,
and I think it's fair to say
we both considered ourselves
liberals or Democrats
or something like that,
that's why I wanted to have
you on, because I thought,
oh, here's someone
sort of on my team,
who's frustrated with
some of the stuff
that I'm frustrated with,
flash forward three years,
where yet in your little
political journey,
before we fully get into the
book and everything else.
- As usual, still having
trouble with labels.
I mean, I wrote an essay called
"Why I Am Not a Progressive,"
so I'm definitely
not a progressive,
I can't accept
that label anymore.
I changed my party
affiliation in April
from Democrat to no
party preference,
which is what we call
independents in California.
I have two books out, one
last year, one this year,
"Apocalypse Never,"
and "San Fran-sicko."
I wrote them in part because
I just wanted to articulate
what I believe,
based on reading the evidence
and what my views are,
because I think labels
are so inadequate.
I think some people,
because some progressives
will call me conservative
or a right-wing lunatic,
of course, a lot of people,
I think, call me a moderate.
"Huffington Post,"
quoted me as a moderate.
as usual as you won't
be surprised to hear,
I mean, there's some
views I have that I think
would be better categorized
as liberal than conservative
and some views that would
be better categorized
as conservative.
And I think there's some things
that not easy to categorize.
- You know, I should
note for the record
that I actually still
am registered as a
Democrat in Cali,
but it's a calculated move
because I wanted to be
able to vote in the primary
so that I could vote,
believe it or not for Biden
in the primary so that
I could stop Bernie.
So that sort of tells you how
politics has become so crazy.
And the system is so nuts
that you stay in a party
to vote against the guy you're
trying to stop the most.
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
I mean, and obviously
the state level,
now we have an open primary
so that you can vote for,
you can have two
Republicans or two Democrats
or two independents
in the runoff.
But yeah, just, honestly,
I changed my party affiliation
because I just don't
feel like it's,
I just couldn't live
with my conscience
to be a Democrat anymore
after working on the new book,
I just felt like, it's just,
I have questions about even,
I mean, I'm sticking
with California,
I'm gonna fight to save
California like you,
but I feel like I'm living in
like Apartheid South Africa
or something.
I just feel like I'm living
in a place that's not moral.
And I feel really bad
and angry about that.
And so, yeah, we
don't want to move,
but the state is pretty
terrible on a lot of levels.
- Yeah, let's sit with
that for a little bit,
because as you know, I
fought really, really hard
for this recall,
I basically was campaigning
with Larry Elder.
The results of this
thing were a disaster.
Now Newsome has codified mail-in
ballots, basically forever.
We have one party rule,
nothing's working,
which is so much of what
your new book's about.
Do you have any hope here?
I'm just having trouble
seeing the hope.
If I could see some
hope, I'd be like,
I could still stay and fight,
but I just don't
see that glimmer.
I don't see that star
in the distance anymore.
- Yeah, I mean,
it's dark right now.
But I think the
darkness just also means
that we just can't see things.
And so we should be humble
too, about our own inability
to view what might be out there.
I will say, I think that
the election heavily,
if you believe the polling,
I think it did heavily
turn on the COVID response.
And I think most
people in California,
and I don't know, you and
I might not agree on this,
but you I think
most Californians
has supported the status
quo view of COVID.
I tweeted something that I
think now is overly pessimistic
about how people voted
for the status quo.
I don't necessarily
think that's true.
We have polling data that
also shows high levels,
75, 80% support for
basically I think the things,
the common sense things that
I think you and I will agree
that we need to do about
the open air drug scenes,
what we euphemistically
call homeless encampments.
So I do think there
is public support
for a lot of the stuff
that we need to change.
But yeah, I mean, I think we
have a leadership challenge.
I surprised myself and I
did feel like I needed to
endorse somebody, I ended
up endorsing Kevin Faulconer
in the recall.
In general, I don't
believe in recalls
because I do think you should
give the guy the four years,
but in this case, I thought
the situation on the streets
was so extreme that
it merited the recall.
So I did endorse the recall
and I endorsed Kevin
Faulconer and yeah.
And then I defended,
you may have seen,
I defended Larry Elder against
the unconscionable attacks
by the racist Antifa woman,
or I don't know if she's
Antifa, so don't sue me,
but the racist woman
in the gorilla mask,
throwing an egg at him
and just the unconscionable
media coverage
by the "LA Times" in particular,
but really all the state
media, clearly, inappropriate.
I mean, I'm sort of
flabbergasted still
by how terrible and biased
the media coverage was.
But yeah, with the book and
certainly and a movement
that we're building, we
have a coalition of groups,
including parents of
kids killed by fentanyl,
including parents whose kids
are addicted to fentanyl
and living on the streets and
who want to get their kids
off the street, including
recovering addicts,
we are advocating for a pretty
sweeping set of reforms.
But yeah, it was discouraging.
- So when you talk to your
liberal lefty friends,
or just like the average
California type person,
one of the things
that I'm still amazed,
now, I do sense a lot
of people waking up
and I think that the election
and the way they treated Larry
was a red pill for
a lot of people.
But still obviously, the
results were basically 70/30,
so obviously out of the voters
they're down with Newsome
and whatever that means.
When you talk to some
of the lefties still,
do they think things
are going well here?
That always seems to be
the confusing part for me,
like who thinks
things are going well?
- No, I mean, my most
progressive friends
are the guys I play soccer with
and they don't think it's okay,
they think it's a big problem.
Part of the reason I
wrote "San Fran-sicko"
is because when I would
raise the problems with them,
including the fact that
the vast majority of people
living on the streets
are addicted to
hard drugs or suffering
mental illness,
they would say to me,
it sounds like you just
want to arrest everybody.
And so I wrote "San
Fran-sicko" in part to say,
here's what I want to do,
here's what I think the plan is.
And we don't have to choose
between mass homelessness
and mass incarceration.
There is a role for the police.
There is a role for laws
and law enforcement,
but that's not the
end of the story.
And we don't want to go back to
"One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest,"
but it's unacceptable
to have these,
100,000, 120,000 people
living on the streets,
using hard drugs, a threat
to themselves and others.
Totally unacceptable.
So, no, I think that
there's actually high levels
of dissatisfaction.
I think we are looking
for leadership,
whether that's coming from
the civil society level
or from the political level.
Somebody has got to step
up and challenge Newsome,
who obviously is up for
reelection next year.
- So it's kind of funny
you wrote "San Fran-sicko,"
obviously about San Francisco.
You happen to be in Venice
right now, just visiting,
I'm in LA at the moment.
So we're only about a half
hour away from each other
and we wanted to
do it in person,
but my schedule is
a little nuts today,
but what's going on in Venice
because it seems like Venice
has been completely destroyed.
- Yeah, so what we call
homeless encampments
is really a euphemism for
what European researchers call
open drug scenes.
"San Fran-sicko" really
describes the whole history
of how did we get here,
but basically we're in the
midst of two overlapping
drug epidemics, as you know,
one, the more famous one,
is around opioids
that started with the
over-prescription of
opioids in the early,
or the late '90s, early 2000s.
We then curtailed
doctor prescriptions
in the run up to 2010.
A lot of people
switched to heroin.
Now a lot of people are
using fentanyl and dying.
93,000 people died last year,
Dave, from illicit drugs,
it's scandalous,
it's a moral failing.
That's almost five times more
people than die from homicides
in the United States.
About three times more than
die from car accidents,
up from 17,000 in the year 2000.
So this is a moral crisis.
It's disproportionally
impacting California.
Homelessness increased
in California 31%
over the last 10 years
while declining 18%
in the rest of
the United States.
So what we're seeing
in Venice Beach,
in the Tenderloin
Neighborhood of San Francisco,
in Skid Row in Los Angeles,
but also in the
Blade Neighborhood of
Seattle in Portland,
where I just visited,
I was just in Portland,
but also in Vancouver.
And now we're seeing
very similar situations
in Philadelphia, the
Kensington neighborhood.
So these are all best referred
to as open drug scenes.
That's I think the right
way to think about them,
that's the academic
word, but you know,
there's only one way
to deal with them,
which is that you have to
require people to use shelter.
You can't let people
camp in public.
I know that sounds
like a radical idea,
but that's not okay.
There is some role for
providing people with housing,
but they should earn
it by making progress
on their personal plan, towards
recovery from addiction,
or taking control of their
psychiatric illnesses.
But we need a
shelter first policy,
we need a treatment
first policy,
the housing first policy we
have has completely failed.
It's basically unethical
because it doesn't actually
try to deal with the root of
the problem which is addiction.
Everything that we
do in California is
a band-aid solution.
So the solution of Venice Beach
was just to try to put people
in some hotel rooms temporarily,
but everybody just ends right
back out on Venice Beach
or in Tenderloin or Skid Row,
because we're not
willing to deal with
the fundamental problem,
which is an addiction crisis.
- Right, so that's actually
one of the themes of the book
that the progressive
and all the cities
you just mentioned, they're
all progressive cities,
that they sort of
say the right thing.
Oh, we'll put them in hotels,
they will be off the street.
It sort of sounds right.
But then you realize that
now they're just doing drugs
in hotels and no one
suddenly gets a job
or gets their life in order.
Is that sort of the
biggest theme to
maybe even a little bit of
your own political evolution
that progressives
are constantly saying
what sounds right and easy,
oh, we're not going to police,
we're not going to
worry about drugs,
we're not gonna do
anything about homes,
it all sounds good, like,
oh, we're trying to
be nice to people,
but the end result is pretty
much everything in your book.
- Yeah, I mean, this was
one of the big questions,
which is sort of why do
people who claim to care
so much about people of color,
the poor, the mentally ill,
the people addicted
to hard drugs,
why is it that the progressives
have allowed the
situation to worsen
so terribly in California?
I debunk all the reasons given,
people say we don't
spend enough money,
we spend more
money than anybody,
and I documented more
money on mental health
than any other state,
worst outcomes.
People say it's because
we don't have enough
permanent supportive
housing, San Francisco,
it's hard to not
go to the title.
San Francisco has more
permanent supportive housing
per capita than any other city,
and it has the worst outcomes.
What's going on here is
that this all boils down to
victim ideology, where
there's this idea
that we can categorize
some people as victims,
that nothing should
be asked of victims,
everything should be given,
including the right
to camp in public,
to use drugs in public,
defecate in public,
engage in even violent
behaviors with no consequences.
It's specific to the West Coast,
it's specific to
progressive cities,
but it is spreading
around the country.
And so, I mean,
there's been various,
one of the funniest things
I interviewed progressives,
I interviewed a lot of
progressives for this book,
by the way, so they're all
in here and I have my own,
you know, I worked
for Maxine Waters
to advocate for needle
exchange, in the late '90s.
I worked for George Soros'
think tanks in the late '90s.
And I still support-
- You have a
progressive pedigree,
there's no doubt about it, yeah.
- So they all talked to
me, everybody talked to me,
and you know, a lot of them,
it was like, they would
say things to me like,
well, this really
started with Reagan.
And I was like,
really like, how so?
They would say, Reagan
let everybody out
of the mental institutions,
as governor, in truth,
it was actually Kennedy who got
deinstitutionalization started,
Reagan didn't do
what he needed to do,
but it's hard to
blame it on him.
People claimed that Reagan
cut the budget for housing.
Really the budget for
housing at the federal level
stayed the same when
he was president,
it declined very small amounts.
Mostly the changes had
nothing to do with him.
Progressives have been
in charge as you know,
in California for
a really long time.
So this is not a problem
that they can put on
anybody else's back.
This is really something
they have to own.
And in fact, you
know, Gavin Newsome,
who used to identify or
position himself anyway,
as a moderate Democrat,
was the person who advocated
the housing first policies
in 2005.
By the way, it was
George W. Bush,
who made that official
federal policy.
So it's really been a bipartisan
policy to some extent,
but the idea that you should
just give people housing,
with no requirements
on behavior change,
has been a progressive,
it's been at the top of the
progressive agenda for 20 years.
- Did you talk to any
of the progressives,
say in San Francisco, here
in LA, like Chesa Boudin
or George Gascon, these
DA's who have decided
not to prosecute basic crimes.
Or even in New York, they're
doing things like this.
If you jump the turnstile,
they won't arrest you.
So you're incentivizing
people to break the law,
but you know, if you steal,
I think it's under $899
worth of stuff at a store,
they basically
won't prosecute you.
So you could get a PlayStation
5 and you get five games,
but you take that sixth game
and now you're in trouble.
I get it, I get it,
they feel like they're
helping somebody
who might need to
steal a carton of milk
or something like that,
not even that that
would make it right.
But do you ever get a
better explanation on stuff,
we all see the videos,
and we're like, geez, we
know this is not right.
- Right, what you're describing
is a selective view of victims.
So progressives are
really concerned
with victims of the system
and they're giving a pass to
victims of other individuals,
so to speak.
So to give an example of it.
Progressives are very
concerned with people
who they feel are being
victimized by police,
than people who are being
victimized by other individuals.
So African-Americans are killed
at a rate 30 times higher
by other civilians than
they are by the police.
And yet there's a huge movement
around police killings,
which is advocating some reforms
that I think are very
positive and we should do,
but there's basically
no movement whatsoever
for reducing homicides among
African-Americans more broadly.
What about drug
addicts on the street
who are often stabbed with
machetes by drug dealers,
if they don't pay
what they owe them,
that's how it gets enforced.
There's just kind of
shrugging of the shoulders
by progressives, that those
crimes and the drug dealers,
according to Chesa Boudin,
most of whom are from Honduras,
not all, but a lot of the,
and that's just in
particular San Francisco,
but the Hondurans control the
drug trade in San Francisco.
And Chesa Boudin has said
that they're victims,
the drug dealers are victims
of human trafficking.
That's not true by the way,
but because there
are people of color
and they're immigrants,
they get put in the
category of victims.
So what I was interested in was
why the selective
categorization of victims.
And what you come
up with is that,
is that progressives
are strictly concerned
with victims of the
system and not concerned
with people that are
victimized by others.
And so one thing was
interesting to me,
I'm working on a column called
the reason they defend
crime is because
they're against capitalism.
Which is that when you
find people defending
the shoplifting, the
complete looting of Walgreens
and drug stores in California,
'cause you can steal,
as you mentioned,
$950 worth of items
without any consequence,
the people who will defend
that are socialists,
who say, well, Walgreens
rips off its workers.
So what you find in the
book in "San Fran-sicko,"
I document a long history
going back, of course,
to the '60s of
antagonism, to the police,
but to the criminal justice
system more broadly.
And this goes back really
to the 19th century,
radical anarchists
and socialists
who viewed crime as
sort of justified
because it was fighting
back against the man.
And so that's where that
selective victimization
comes from.
I felt the need to
write "San Fran-sicko"
because I think when
my progressive soccer
buddies read it
and you kind of lay it out,
where is this
ideology coming from?
And you realize that, yeah,
it's really that stupid.
You get to the bottom of it,
and you're like, wow, that dumb.
You're like, I thought it maybe
would be more sophisticated,
but it's just that
stupid at bottom.
- Let's go there, there.
- Once you make it explicit,
I think it's harder for
people to defend it.
- Does it sort of
impress you almost?
I mean, I ask almost all my
guests this at this point,
it's caused so much destruction,
this radical ideology,
and destroyed so
many institutions,
literally destroyed cities,
it's destroying colleges,
it's destroying basically the
fabric of American society.
Do you somehow admire it
in some weird perverse way?
I mean, even in the
last couple of days,
we're holding this
interview for a few days,
but in the last couple of days,
Kyrsten Sinema got
chased into that bathroom
at Arizona State University.
And I saw an incredible
amount of progressives
and progressive news
organizations defending her.
Oh yeah, you can get
up in their face,
which by the way is
exactly what Maxine Waters
has been on the record
saying, get in their face,
that you almost
admire their absolute
relentless pursuit
of destruction.
- Yeah, I mean there's, and
there's a cunning to it.
There's a cleverness to the
manipulation of language
in particular.
Just take a simple
word like homelessness,
I traced the genealogy
of this word back,
it's a propaganda word, it's
always been a propaganda word,
designed to mix together
two totally different
groups of people.
One is the proverbial
mother escaping
an abusive husband
with her two kids,
who doesn't have anywhere
to go that night,
mixing her together with people
suffering from schizophrenia,
who were on the streets,
often addicted to hard drugs,
or people that are just
addicted to hard drugs,
mixing those
populations together,
deliberately confusing
two groups of people
who require completely
different things.
And by the way, we
do a pretty good job
taking care of the mom,
escaping the abusive husband.
She needs something different
than someone with schizophrenia,
and that person that
has schizophrenia
needs something
different than someone
who's just addicted to heroin.
But the word homelessness
suggests that the only response
should be a charitable response.
When sometimes you do need
to involve law enforcement
to either make sure
the laws are enforced,
and also to compel treatment,
because it's not compassionate
to let people die
from drug overdose
on the street.
Look, if someone wants
to kill themselves
in the privacy of
their own home, fine,
but we don't allow people to
kill themselves on the street.
That's not something
that's consistent with
a civilized society.
So yeah, I can admire the
cunning, the manipulation,
but there's just something
really sociopathic
about all of it.
I mean, there's a view.
I heard a lot of
people say things like
our unhoused population and it
just gave me the creeps dude.
It was just like, they're
not your population.
They're not objects
for you to control.
These are often people
that you're contributing
in their victimization out
of some hatred of the system.
So yeah, I it's scary, dude.
- I remember when I was lefty
and they would always say fam
like, we're fam and I hated
it because it was like,
you're not my family, we
may be friends or a group
and we all kind of have common
cause in some of this stuff.
But like, you also hate family,
like they hate the
family structure,
but we're fam because we have
some like ideological cohesion
or something like that.
- There's a lot in that forced,
they call it forced teaming,
that sort of sense
of compliance,
there's also a lot of menace
there, if you don't conform,
you'll be ostracized and
stigmatized and all the rest.
- So as you talk
about this stuff
and as you write this
stuff and go through
whatever your own
political evolution is,
you're having a similar
experience to what
happened with me,
which is I sense you're finding
that people on the right
generally aren't that bad,
you've done some stuff
with with Prager,
scary Dennis Prager.
And I think you've had
conversations with Ben Shapiro
and a couple other people,
how's that been for you?
And have there been red
lines with those guys
that you've said something
that was so outlandish,
so crazily left,
that they didn't want
to talk to you anymore,
or didn't want to air something
or wanted to censor something
or silence you, et cetera?
- No, I mean, that
is shocking, right?
Which is that if you go
on a conservative TV show,
your progressive friends,
it's so upsetting to them that
the friendship is threatened.
Whereas if you go
on a liberal show,
nobody on the right
seems to care.
And so it's clearly,
this is my second book,
I'm writing a trilogy
and the book's,
"Apocalypse Never,"
came out last year,
"San Fran-sicko" is
coming out next Tuesday,
I've got a third
book in the works.
And these are books really about
how these threats
to civilization and
the institutions
that support civilization
are coming from people in the
grip of a religious fervor.
This is a fanaticism,
and what's at stake for, you
know, for when, you know like,
you kind of like,
so you go on a show with
somebody you don't like,
why would that threaten
like a friendship?
why would that break up,
why would that be such
a threat to somebody?
It's because they have so
much of their identities
riding on their
political identity,
so much of themselves on
their political identity,
so that people's politics
have become their new gods,
new religions.
It's interesting because
when new religions form,
they are more fanatical
and more apocalyptic,
than they become over time,
they start more extreme.
So what's scary is
that this is a new,
is that this is a new religion
that's asserting its
control over the society.
We have to push back against it.
We have to expose
how harmful it is.
Part of the reason I wanted
to write "San Fran-sicko"
was it's not just
the universities.
There's real victims
of these policies,
93,000 deaths last year.
I'm not going to say all of
them are due to these policies,
but we went from 17,000, 20
years ago to 93,000 last year.
That's a lot of dead bodies.
- What's a non-progressive city
that's kind of doing
this stuff, right.
I've bounced around the
country, I'm sure you have.
I went to Salt Lake City, it
was pretty freaking clean,
everybody was decent, I
didn't see homeless people,
i didn't see people doing
drugs on the street.
I was in New York
city last week,
I have to say it was more open
than I thought it was going
to be, which was nice.
But there were cops on
basically every single corner
and almost every
corner was barricaded.
And there were a ton,
I mean around Midtown,
a ton of people on drugs
and people just
laying in the streets.
- Yeah, New York has gotten
worse for sure, though, really,
When you say which cities
have done it better
than progressive
West Coast Cities,
the answer is all
of them, basically.
New York shelters 99, or at
least it did until the pandemic,
it sheltered 99% of
all its homeless.
We shelter about a third in
California and it's very simple.
You have to build
enough shelters.
The progressive homeless
advocates, I put it in quotes,
have denied funding
for the shelters.
They've taken money away from
building sufficient
shelter space
and put it into this
really expensive,
$700,000 to million dollar
apartment unit housing,
which is grossly insufficient.
Miami has done a pretty good job
in terms of dealing
with this population.
New York did better.
I really look at Amsterdam
in the book as my model,
because it's such
a progressive city,
it's such a liberal city,
it's hard to be against it.
Their sex work is
basically legal,
you can smoke marijuana and
go to the Van Gogh exhibit,
it's a very progressive city,
but yet there aren't big
homeless encampments.
And when you talk to them
about how they dealt with it,
it was always social workers
and police working together.
So it's not like
there's any mystery
in terms of how you
solve the problem.
It's more like why
won't we do it?
And I think that's
where I tell you,
it's really about
a victim ideology.
- Right, so how do
we get the lefties
out of this a little bit,
you're talking about sort
of the religious fervor,
that the ideas are
sort of antithetical
to what is actually working.
Have you figured out a way to
make any headway with them?
They generally, at
least from where I'm at,
seem to double down
when things don't work.
Oh, it didn't work, not
because of what we did,
but because of those guys,
sort of like your Reagan
answer from before,
have you figured out any
tricks in this little period
that you've been doing this?
- Well, I don't know
if it's a trick,
but I do think you have to,
we have to have
a proper solution
to the addiction and
psychiatric crisis,
which is really what is driving,
what we call homelessness,
and this is not
to do with crime,
which is a separate issue we
could, we could talk about it,
or at least not with homicide,
but so we've come
up in the book.
I propose something
called Cal Psych,
which would be basically
taking over from the counties,
which can't deal
with this problem
because street addicts are an
incredibly transient population.
They move from city to city,
often to escape law enforcement,
or just because things go bad.
We need a single agency
to deal with this.
It needs to be a psychiatric
and mental health response,
an addiction response.
It also would allow us to
have drug treatment facilities
in places like Fresno.
If you're addicted and breaking
the law on Venice Beach
and you get arrested and offered
to either to jail or prison
or to go get drug treatment,
then there's no reason you
need to be in Venice Beach,
where real estate values are
really high and expensive,
and it's hard to
build something,
you can go to Fresno and do it.
So in my progressive friends
say, what do you want to do?
I say, I want to do this
thing called Cal Psych.
If anybody should have
a problem with it,
it should be conservatives,
it should be libertarians.
And I spend the very
last few chapters
of "San Fran-sicko"
interviewing the leading
conservative thinkers
on this proposal.
And they all support
it, so Chris Rufo,
who's famous for
Critical Race Theory,
before that he was a
really important researcher
on homelessness and drugs.
He is on board with this.
I interview a top scholar
at Manhattan Institute,
which is an important
center-right think tank,
they're onboard with this.
Republicans have sort of
privately acknowledged
that the state
needed to take over
psychiatric and addiction care,
but it hasn't been
something that has been
at the center of their agenda.
So my hope is that some
center-right candidate,
and by the way,
it could be a Democrat,
Independent, or Republican,
it doesn't have
to be Republican,
will pick up Cal
psych and run with it.
And we made some headway
with Kevin Faulconer
in the recall, he certainly,
I think over time,
started to understand why you
need to have a single state
provide this service.
But I do think that
would be game changing
because I think that starts
to look a lot closer to
psychiatry for all,
universal psychiatry,
which is something that
progressives should embrace.
And then the only thing that
comes along with it is that,
if you're going to have
psychiatry for all,
you can't just go and do
your hard drugs in public,
there need to be some
consequences as well.
When we put that
together with polling,
we find 70 to 80% support.
In fact, we found
stronger support among
Democrats than Republicans,
because so many
Republicans felt like
that was already being
a little bit too soft,
and that people should
just go to jail.
- Right, right, was there any
polling on how things changed
over the last two years?
Not only because of lockdown,
but also because of the riots,
and the riots were getting
pretty close to my last house.
I no longer live there.
I'm not sure how much longer
I'll live in this house.
Like that changed.
We know that California had its
first net loss of population
in the history of
the state last year.
- Yeah, I haven't
seen any change.
I would be surprised if
the basic attitudes change,
because I think the basic
attitudes on this issue
towards people
with mental illness
and people with drug
addictions are formed from
kind of pretty core liberal
or conservative values,
depending on how you
think of bad things like
human nature and society.
These issues of are you
a victim of society,
or victim of individuals,
tends to just be
a kind of a core,
almost unconscious part
of people's thinking.
But what I will say
I think has changed
is that it is now viewed
as a threat to public order
and public health.
And that it's not just,
you see the encampments
everywhere now.
And so I think that's
had a big impact
in terms of increasing
what pollsters
call the salience of the issue.
when you ask, well, what's
the most important issue
facing California?
What they say is COVID,
that's number one,
and number two, they
say homelessness.
And COVID is gonna,
that's going to go away
or it's going to be dealt with,
so I would say, if I
were advising someone
to challenge Gavin Newsome,
I would say you probably
just want to agree with them
on the COVID response, that
might be hard for conservatives,
but I would just agree with
them on the COVID response,
and just challenge them
on the homelessness issue,
because honestly
you could implement
much of what he has promised
to do, and hasn't done.
You could promise to do that,
and I think people would
be on board with that.
Because he's given good rhetoric
to a lot of these things,
but hasn't had the
kind of software
or courage to be able to
stand up against the ACLU
and the radical left within
the Democratic Party.
Somebody that I think
embrace a treatment first,
shelter first approach
along with Cal Psych,
I think could make
a lot of headway,
particularly if
they just kind of
conceded the issue of COVID,
which I just think
most Californians
agree with the status quo on.
- Yeah, man, I mean, I hope
you would be right on that.
I just think it's
so weird to me,
how many people here
seemingly are brainwashed,
even on the COVID stuff,
and I'm not sure we're
in full agreement,
which obviously wouldn't
wouldn't matter to me,
that so many people
voted for the guy
who was locking everybody down
while he was eating in the
most expensive restaurant
in the state. and the
first thing that he did
after getting reelected or
after the recall failed,
the first thing he did
was basically get LA
to institute new measures.
I can't imagine
what it's like being
in the brain of those people,
but maybe that's just me.
- Yeah, and I think, I
mean, you probably can
in the sense that
California has changed a lot
over the last 20 years,
people are much wealthier.
All of us that own, 65%
of voters are homeowners.
If you own a home, you
saw your wealth increase
so dramatically over
the last 10, 20 years.
And you know, people
are pretty neurotic,
man, I mean, you know, you
live in LA, I live in Berkeley.
people will give me bad looks
if I was not wearing a mask
on a nature trail, like
10 feet away from them.
so there's a lot of neuroticism
that I think is stronger among,
so it's a much more
progressive electorate
than it was 10 or 20 years ago.
It's a much more
neurotic electorate.
But I think that that
is not necessarily,
it has been annoying
for conservatives
and even for maybe moderates
like myself on COVID issues,
'cause I do think kids should
have gone back to school
right away.
But I do think that
that neuroticism
and the concern
around public health
around public order
does favor change when
it comes to dealing with
the open drug scenes that we
call homeless encampments.
- You mentioned the religious
fervor behind this earlier,
and as you're talking
about the neuroticism now,
it seems to me that
if you have this
secular idea on steroids,
this government's going to
do everything on steroids,
it leads to this sort
of crazy neuroticism
because government can't
solve all of your problems
and you're constantly looking
to it as you would God,
or whatever it is
that you believe in.
I'm wondering if that
tracks with where you're at
politically too,
'cause I've seen a bunch
of my liberal friends
that are on a similar
trajectory as me,
that now we're either believers
that weren't believers
or at least questioning or
something along those lines.
- Oh yeah, for sure,
and I think that like,
I want to distinguish between
the progressive activists
who have the victim
ideology and control policy,
to a large extent
at the state level,
in terms of Housing
First, ACLU, those folks,
I want to distinguish from them,
and say my hairdresser who
voted for Bernie Sanders,
who also is upset about
the homeless situation,
the open drug scenes,
she's more in that 70 to 80%
that I think would favor
a more balanced response
of both carrots and sticks
in terms of a shelter first,
treatment first approach,
rather than a housing
first approach.
So I think the challenge again,
I think there is a
leadership problem.
I mean, you need to have
somebody who can articulate
that vision and
explain it to people.
'Cause you know, when you
get people in a conversation
like a focus group, rather
than in like an instant,
if you're using
type two thinking,
slow thinking rather
than fast thinking,
I think people
are more attentive
to the need for a balance,
that you shouldn't
just be able to,
we still have a very deep
reciprocity motivation,
which is if you give
somebody something
you should expect
something in return,
progressives are violating that.
And this idea of you just
giving street addicts
anything they want
and not asking for
public order and public
behavior in return.
So that seems to me,
that's the soft underbelly
of the progressive
agenda in California.
Honestly, I think it's
the soft underbelly
of Democrats nationwide.
I think Republicans should
be doing a lot more with it,
which is that, here
is this big package,
this big budget package
is going to give what,
a couple more years
of college education,
some childcare credits,
but what's it doing
about the most important
cause of death,
accidental cause of death.
I mean here, the
FDA finally issued a
one pill can kill advisory,
but I mean like we're seeing,
kids who experiment,
thinking they're taking
a half a Percocet,
buying it from a
dealer on Snapchat,
are dying in their bedrooms,
being found by their parents.
I mean, Michael K. Williams,
the great actor from "The Wire,"
who died from fentanyl
poisoning, Prince, Tom Petty.
I mean, you know, fentanyl
changes everything
in terms of this is not
just an addiction problem,
we're now dealing
with active poisoning,
and Democrats are
just not to be found
anywhere in dealing with this.
So I do think there
is room for maneuver,
I do think it's a
dark moment right now,
but there's so much
chaos in the system
in the last four
years, we've seen that,
that something is
going to change,
the system can't
maintain its instability
for many more years.
I think Republicans
are moving in
a lot of the issues
that you and I think
probably had concerns
with Republicans
over 10 or 20 years ago are
just not issues anymore.
I see the progress that's,
like one of the characters
in my book is Harvey Milk,
the gay rights leader.
I asked my publisher,
I was like,
are I conservative readers
going to have a problem
with Harvey Milk?
And he was like, no,
that issue is gone.
So a lot of the social
issues seem to be
moving to the background
and we see new issues
coming to the forefront
that I do think open
up possibilities
for some challenge to
progressive orthodoxy.
- It's interesting, as
you were mentioning that,
I may have told you this
story three years ago,
but when I interviewed David
Horowitz the first time
and David Horowitz was
sort of the original YLF,
the left guy,
he told the story about how he
was a Marxist his whole life,
a leftist, his parents
were communists.
And then in 1984, he liked
Reagan during the reelection.
So he says, you know,
basically I'm leaving the left.
And then he told me this
story about how in New York,
at the peak of the AIDS crisis,
that all of the public
health officials,
who basically they were lefties,
it was run by mostly Democrats,
that they all knew
that it was emanating
from the gay bathhouses,
like they just knew people
were doing drugs there,
they were having
unprotected sex,
and they knew it was
all coming from there.
And they knew that
all of these people,
young people were
dying every day,
hundreds and
thousands were dying.
And that the conservatives
who had really no power,
the Republicans in New
York City came in and said,
well, okay, we got to
close the bath houses,
that's how we have
to do something here.
And it was the
Democrats who said,
no, because they
didn't want to infringe
on those people's
lifestyle to be,
and they called they called
them homophobes basically.
Anyway, I'm just
reminded them of that,
because it's so
consistent with everything
that you're saying here.
- Yeah, because the
victimization or the
spread of HIV/AIDS
was occurring at the
individual level,
rather than something being
imposed by the system.
And so, yeah,
you have to remember
progressives
start from the point of view
that the system is evil,
and it's basically
a Rousseauian idea
that the individual
is innocent and good,
and that the society
is what's corrupting.
And conservatives, just
to really dumb it down
to kind of big crayon level,
and conservatives are more
like humans are fallen
and society is what keeps us
on the straight and narrow.
And I think that's still
very much alive here.
It's why we allow people to
be killed by drug dealers,
killed by civilians,
but just everything changes
when people are perceived as
being victimized by the state.
- Like literally, if you
bring up black on black crime,
they'll tell you you're
a racist, I mean,
that's your point.
- Yeah, yeah, and I mean,
here's the interesting thing.
I'm interested in hearing
your view of it too.
I mean, to declare all
black people victims,
that's totally racist.
And the idea that all
white people are privileged
is also racist.
And when you really kind of
listen to it for a minute,
you go, so let me
get this straight,
you're saying that all
white people are privileged
and all black people are victims
and you think that's not racist,
that's the most racist thing.
Victimology is actually
bigger than that, of course,
it encompasses that
kind of racism.
But it also suggests that
a whole set of other people
are basically, that
people are powerless,
that people that you put
in the category of victims
are powerless, and therefore,
one of the
consequences of course
is that we shouldn't do
anything to prevent them
from being victimized
because doing so
would only exacerbate
the victimization.
One of the, sorry, go ahead.
- Well, you, you know
my feelings on this,
but I'll tell you this,
look, I have Larry
Elder coming to my house
for dinner tonight, Larry
Elder, born in South Central,
dad was a janitor, does not
view himself as a victim,
and is not a victim.
And I have one of my best
friends from childhood,
whose son right now, who's
white, which doesn't matter,
other than for the
purposes of this story,
his son is hooked on
fentanyl right now.
And and it's like,
he grew up privileged
in that his dad had a job.
So it's like, none of
this makes any sense.
- I'll give you, I'll
tell you something.
I've been obsessed with this,
with one of the fathers of
cognitive behavioral therapy
named Victor Frankl.
Who's famous because
he wrote a book called
"Man's Search for Meaning,"
and he's one of the original
humanistic psychologists
of the 1960s.
His whole book, "Man's
Search For Meaning,"
is about how he survived
the concentration camps
under the Nazis.
And he did so by changing his
mentality and getting a goal
and his goal was, survive
the concentration camps,
find my wife and parents,
and write a book
about the experience.
And so his whole thing was
mentality, mentality, mentality,
forget about how bad
the situation is,
mentality is everything.
And he was loved by
progressives in the '60s.
Viktor Frankl's book,
"Man's Search for Meaning."
He sold like 10 million copies.
During the pandemic, when
I was in some dark moments,
I'd watch like these five
minute YouTube videos
of Victor Frankel talking,
and suddenly I felt
enthusiastic about life.
And if you take Victor Frankel's
core message of empowerment,
which I think is the
Larry Elder message,
that you are describing as well,
which is that you
can change your life,
you can take control and be
responsible for your life,
but somehow progressive said,
that's fine for self-help,
but in politics, it's
blaming the victim,
to suggest that people have
control over their lives,
to suggest that people
responsibility and agency
and empowerment was viewed
as blaming the victim.
And boy, what a disservice
and what a destructive view,
this idea that you should
categorize people as victims
and suggest they're powerless.
- Well that's why I always
say, it's anti-human actually,
because the one thing that
separates us from the animals
is our ability to logic
and reason and dream
and pursue and have passion
for something and build,
that was a lot of things that
I combined into one thing,
but like, that's the
thing, that's the thing.
And they're saying,
no, it's not yours,
it's ours to
somehow give to you.
- And that seems to me,
in terms of fighting back
against the radical left
and the dehumanization
that you're describing
and the disempowerment,
that seems to me, to be at
the soft underbelly as well.
We, I think have
a natural instinct
to not want to perceive
ourselves as victims.
In fact, in the book,
I describe a fair amount of
homeless guys will confess
that they were just
playing the victim,
that they don't
actually perceive them,
homeless guys living on
the streets don't actually
perceive themselves as victims.
And I think in part,
because it's like,
that's a terrible way to live.
It's a depressive way to live
and it's hard to sustain it.
They might pretend
that for a bit.
But I think that really,
you're onto something
really powerful here,
which is, and I think that
all of your work, honestly,
Dave, has been really
creative and productive
when you're talking
about this question of
psychological health,
that the extension of
psychological health
and one's own life in politics
should be one of empowerment.
I don't think that means that,
I think when it comes to
things like healthcare,
that we still may need a
universal psychiatric program,
but it has to be paired
with this idea that
people are capable of taking
responsibility for their lives,
even people, frankly, with
disabilities and addictions
and in all sorts of
terrible circumstances,
all the more reason that
they should be empowered
to take power and
responsibility for their lives.
- And of course,
that's the irony
because as I've become, say
more libertarian in general,
and people say, well, you
don't care about these people
or something like that.
Now at first off, it's
not an honest statement,
because it's like,
they're usually doing
nothing for them either,
they're just screaming about
it, they're pretending,
or they want the state to do
it, but they're pretending.
But I think even bigger
than that is sort of like,
well, if any of
the stuff worked,
if you gave me
policies that worked,
some of the things you
were describing here,
then it's like, oh, we should
fund those things properly.
But if you consistently show
me things that don't work
and keep people trapped
in this cycle of poverty
and everything else,
well then yeah,
I don't need my
money going to it.
And it's not even about money,
I just don't need,
that's not how society
should operate.
- That's right,
and if any advice comes
out of "San Fran-sicko"
for libertarians
and for the right,
it's just that we should
lead with what we want to do,
which is, I think that's
why I sort of say,
I want the modified, I
want to modify Dutch,
I just want to do
what the Dutch do.
I mean, why do I want
to do what the Dutch do?
It's some ideological
predisposition,
it's because it works so darn
well, there's nobody on the,
there's hardly
anybody on the street,
very few people on the street,
marijuana is basically
decriminalized,
but they have the most humane
treatment of the mentally ill,
the most humane
treatment of addicts.
It's exactly what you said,
but it's got a balance.
We've got to restore
some balance here.
And I think that's
the kind of thing
that my progressive
soccer buddies
and my hairdresser and the
folks that voted for Bernie,
I think that's what the
vast majority of them want.
They just want to see
some balance restored,
that if we're going
to give something,
we should get
something in return.
- Yeah, you know, it's
interesting on the sort of
be careful what
you ask for thing,
I'm completely for
legalizing medical
and well medical, certainly,
and recreational marijuana
and some psychedelics
and things like that.
But I will tell you when I
was in New York last week,
a lot of the street corners
that used to smell like urine,
they smell like weed.
I'm actually not sure if
that's good, you know,
it just is what
it is, I suppose.
- No, I appreciate
you saying that,
I have some real concerns about
what we might call the IDW's
excitement about psychedelics.
It's showing up on
my Instagram page
that I can take psychedelics
and there's no downside to them.
I've become much more
sensitive to that.
I've always been an advocate
of decriminalizing marijuana.
My view is that we have
amazing drugs available to us,
more than ever in history,
and they're very powerful
and they're different,
we have to have more
complex view of drugs,
drugs are different
from one another,
nobody overdoses from marijuana,
but a little bit of
fentanyl can kill you.
So these are two
different drugs.
But you can abuse marijuana
and marijuana can have
really harmful impacts.
And so this is again where
you just have to have
a system of care.
You know, we know
that ecstasy, MDMA,
works well with victims
of extreme trauma
who are having a hard time
overcoming their PTSD.
There's some evidence that
some of the other psychedelics
have some benefit
as antidepressants.
They need to be done under
supervised circumstances.
I mean, this is wild
west out here, and again,
I think this has been a
traditional sensitive issue,
both for right libertarians,
but also for left
libertarians like ACLU.
But I kind of go, I don't
know what the problem is
of having psychiatry
involved in helping to guide
people's use of those drugs,
because maybe they'll have
some benefit for people
or maybe they won't,
maybe they would be
better off taking an SSRI,
maybe medical marijuana
is better for some people
than an SSRI,
but you do need some kind of
professional care
involved in that.
Or I think you just end
up with 120,000 people
on the streets
addicted to hard drugs.
- The best lines, since
you mentioned the IDW,
the best line that I
heard on psychedelics,
was when I was on
tour with Jordan,
people would often
ask in the Q&A,
what do you think
about psychedelics?
What do you think about magic
mushrooms, blah, blah, blah.
And his answer was
always the same,
be wary of unearned wisdom.
And I always thought
that was like,
you kind of said it
all pretty succinctly.
- Absolutely, yeah.
And I think we
under-emphasize things
that are probably more boring,
but at least for me personally,
in my own mental health have
been much more important,
like exercise, it's so boring,
and everyone gets sick
of me talking about,
but I'm kind of like
if I don't exercise
like a hard exercise
every other day,
then I'm just not
right mentally.
And I think there's just a
lot of people where I'm like,
I see people looking for a
kind of a medicine or something
to take rather than
doing other things
that are much better
for self care.
- that's actually where I
wanted to end this with you.
That as you've been
on this journey,
I wonder, just your
life in general,
whether it's your relationships,
physical body, mental,
spiritual, I can say my
life is significantly better
on all fronts.
Confronting the ideologies
that I had to break through
and let go of some things and
traverse that new territory
and find out that people
I thought were scary,
aren't that scary,
and some of the things
that I believe weren't,
and then that translated
into actually taking
better care of
myself, physically,
mentally, spiritually,
and everything else.
I sense you're kind
of in a similar spot.
- I am, thank you for asking.
And I really appreciate
how you shared
your own personal journey with
your videos over the years.
I've found it really
inspiring and brave.
'Cause I know it's
not easy to do,
to share some of these things,
it's certainly not easy for me.
Yeah, I mean, just
like you said,
I basically couldn't
finish "Apocalypse Never"
until I came back to my faith,
until I felt like,
until I stopped being
embarrassed about my faith
and believing actually
that it was okay
for my psychological
health to have faith.
In fact, that was
quite important to it.
I also stopped drinking three
years ago, almost exactly.
And it was one of
the best decisions
I ever made for my life.
I think about how to talk
about it and in the end,
I decided not to write about
that in "San Fran-sicko,"
which is nice that
you ask about it,
because I felt like I didn't
want to compare my situation
to people on the street
'cause that's a really
different situation,
but it did make my life better,
and it was what I needed to do
because I wasn't able to
get control of my drinking
in a moderate way.
And for sure, all the things
that you hear really matter,
family, faith, sobriety,
and then I would
just add exercise,
have been really
important for me
in dealing with tough times.
- Crazy right-wing stuff, huh.
Mike, it was good to seeing you,
we will do this in person
next time, I promise.
And good luck with the book,
we're going to link
to it down below
and I'll talk to you soon.
- It's great to see
you again, thanks Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right, over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.